so the question is does section 3 of the
14th amendment
apply to president trump in the sense
that it bars
people who have committed sedition from
holding office in the united states
putting aside the question of whether
president trump actually committed
sedition or not
the 14th amendment this particular
clause was enabled to prevent
members of the confederacy from holding
office in the federal government again
and for better or worse
this section the 14th amendment has
almost never been used because almost as
soon as congress passed it
they granted a waiver to almost everyone
that served for the south
in the civil war and there are tons of
open questions in terms of whether this
is self-executing whether you actually
have to hold a trial
and we just don't know the answer to
these questions right now
so it's a completely open question if it
applies to president trump and to what
extent it does
so stay tuned for more election coverage
and i'll see you in court